what did you learn about porn when you
looked at that
for the book
the thing with porn that i think a lot
of people don't
fully appreciate is that
online porn is a completely different
beast
from like playboy of the 60s i mean i
start the book by writing about playboy
writing like hugh hefner and clearly
like there were
feminists writing at the time about porn
being really grim for women there's this
famous cover of a
an issue of hustler i can't remember
what year it was published in probably
70s
where a woman is being like
um ground up in a meat grinder and her
legs are just sticking out the top it's
really like
of like deliberately grotesque image and
feminist got so upset about it at the
time i think rightly but like they had
no idea
what would happen with the internet
and i think that the thing that's so
sinister
about online porn is
that
there's this there's this quote i use in
the book
that
the nature of like technicalism
is that we are all either above the
algorithm or below the algorithm we're
either
writing these we're either creating
these these these pieces of tech or
we're being influenced by them because
we're using them or we're you know
sexually interacting with people who are
using them and porn is such an amazing
example of this because
it's just profit driven that's the point
of it it's not it's not interested in
the well-being of its consumers i mean
whatever pornhub like pornhub have
various like advertising efforts to try
and sanitize what they do but
the whole the whole point of it is
making money and they're really good at
it and the way that they do it is by
basically creating a super stimulus
which
adults uses brains
and the
like they're incredibly adept at
basically arousing the human body the
human animal like we can't really resist
our animal instincts as quickly as
possible so you log on to
one of these platforms and you look at
the front page
and like everything is designed to make
you as horny as possible as quickly as
possible
and
the
the way the platforms are designed
is to
like introduce you to the super stimulus
and then introduce it to something even
more stimulating and even more
stimulating even more stimulating and so
you end up and i mean so a lot of people
are able to use porn casually quite a
lot of people don't use it at all like i
surprised including men surprising
proportion do you know how much that is
so i read a survey that about a quarter
of millennial men haven't used in the
last month
which quite a lot
but the the
there's a minority of users who are like
helpless power users this yeah yeah like
again it's it burrito is a play as well
like there is a small
number of men who watch i can't remember
the the figure i put in the book it's
something like two percent of users use
it for like seven hours a week or more
it's a lot of porn do you know um mary
harrington's law of fap entropy
yes whatever you start out wanking to
will get progressively more disgusting
over time and you'll be down in the
depths of blueberry porn before you know
it well yeah
yeah absolutely yeah i mean
like just anecdotally there are some
very strange things that compulsive porn
users end up
being turned on by and like to the point
where they they can't even
like erectile dysfunction being a huge
problem they can't actually have sex
with a real person what's the name for
that
it's not ground pounding what's it
called it's called something
oh death grip syndrome death ground
pounding where the [ __ ] did i pull that
from yeah
more unpleasant
i mean death grip syndrome isn't that
nice either
yeah and i talk i write in the book
about um cultural death grip syndrome
which is where we've got an incredibly
pornified public life you've got so much
more like sex scenes on tv
advertising billboards whatever i mean
like sex scenes on tv have wrapped up so
quickly just in my lifetime that used to
be edgy and now it's like
you know every drama has to have
like super super explicit sex scenes
every five minutes whatever
so you've got that on the one hand well
i don't think we've ever had this much
explicit sex in public life but then
also people aren't actually having sex
you have the sex recession with sex
depression
where you've got as you were saying
you've got loads of men who are virgins
up into their 20s and so on it's this
really weird
um
what's the word
it's this really weird contradiction and
it's one that the feminists of the 70s
who were so upset about porn didn't
foresee interestingly like they were
concerned that porn would
inspire sexual violence and like
it's complicated because it probably
does a bit like in some circumstances so
for instance
choking porn has become so popular
and is so mainstream in a way that it
wasn't at all 20 years ago it used to be
considered a really niche media sim
thing and even actually in the bsn
community it was considered a bit risky
whereas now
like
survey data is crazy
for millennials and younger the
proportion of young women who report
being choked by their partners
um sometimes asking for it and sometimes
sometimes non-consensually but it's like
just become insanely mainstream really
quickly and the only mechanism
that i can see for that is porn that
it's it's inspiring a change in sexual
culture so
so sometimes yeah it's inspiring
more
aggressive behavior from its users
but equally actually sometimes it's like
basically neutering
users like they become actually
incapable of having sex with a real
person and even becoming capable of
being aroused by just normal porn
because they're so
they'd like they go they go down the
rabbit hole
yeah
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you